come here let's talk get away from my
mom
what are you gonna do with that
[Music]
vincent welcome back and we have to say
it was so satisfying to see your return
uh can you tell us what was it like to
get that call from marvel like were you
surprised when did they reach out
um earlier very early in the year
um they reached out it was kevin
actually kevin called me and invited me
to do hawkeye
and you can imagine i was extremely
excited about that when he did
and so uh yeah that's that's how it
happened no fans have been very vocal
about having kingpin and you return so
what can you tell us about this take on
the role like are we seeing the same
kingpin as before is this the same or
different portrayal no it's the same
kingpin i mean he's obviously um has
more physical strength and can take a
lot more physical abuse
but
from uh from
from story point of view it was
discussed that this is after the blip
that he is the same guy that was in
daredevil but he's lost some of his
power and that and the
my arc in hawkeye is that i want my
power back and so from an actress point
of view i'd i'm portraying him exactly
with the same kind of emotional feel and
foundation that i did in in daredevil in
hong kong
all right so like you said you've
interacted with daredevil
and in this series you've crossed paths
with hawkeye and kate bishop if you had
to choose who in the mcu
would you
you know want to go up against and why
i think because of the history of the
comic books i think kingpins
um when i was a kid i i
punished her daredevil and spiderman
spiderman
and i still think that that kingpin
you know that it would be nice my hope
is that someday we all get to face all
those in the character of kingpin i hope
so too
yeah that would be so fun because you
know what i watched the season finale
yesterday and i'm not convinced i refuse
to believe that this is the end for
kingpin can you share a little bit of
details as to when and where we might
see him again no i don't know i can only
hope that we do it i mean
i think that it would be great and um i
think we just all have to keep our
fingers crossed that it's that it
happens
fingers crossed
now could you describe your experience
being on set again like this time on a
new show um and with new faces how was
it like it was so fun but honestly it
was i mean beer i've worked with before
so i know that she's a wonderful actress
i mean so good so doing the scene with
her was we did it so quickly and so
precisely and i was just you know i'm
always so impressed by her and and and
then um with hayley you know haley and i
didn't have
um
a real a lot of dialogue but that fight
scene was very technical and i was
really impressed with her her work ethic
and and um and she just seemed such like
such a powerhouse on set it was really
really nice and then with alekwa and and
and fra i mean the two of them are both
amazing actor and actress i mean they're
just
so good i love to be impressed by young
people and i was definitely impressed
you know it was really quiet something
it um
you know
to be around
young people with that kind of work
ethic and that kind of talent it
inspires me you know so it's uh a one
that was wonderful it was a wonderful
thing
[Music]
you